you know he wants to be bigger than fdr
and obama and
and uh and johnson and that's all he
cares about
biden is a very dumb guy he's a he's an
ego maniac he's always wanted to be
bigger than really his capabilities
that's why he plagiarized as a young man
that's why he stole words from robert
kennedy and neil connect when he was
running
back then we actually had standards so
that knocked him out of the running for
president
yeah people don't know that he
plagiarized and that actually got him to
step down
from the democratic primary i think like
88 or so
today it would be like who cares um
so he's always he's always he's always
been that way but he's always been for
biden
and that's what you're seeing now
do you think that there is something
connected to belief
that plays a role in all of this i've
sensed that with my liberal friends
that come from a more purely secular
position on this
that their their underbelly is just too
soft it's it's too sort of we accept
everything
so yeah we'll kind of go down the road
to hell with you
when you get it from faith i get it from
somewhere else
if you don't believe in existential
truths
and if you don't believe in look
the golden rule the ten commandments is
there a problem with the golden rule and
the ten commandments i don't think so
well those are the fundamentals really
when you when you when you write them
down that's the fundamental
you look at the declaration of
independence the reason why that
document is so
incredible these men they knew about
judeo-christian history
many of them were practicing christians
these men knew all about the
enlightenment the reformation they
studied it they studied
aristotle and cicero and you name it
they knew they were well-educated men
and they put together this declaration
of independence they put everything on
the line
everything on the line so look at that
declaration of independence
abraham lincoln cited the declaration
over and over and over again during the
civil war
and one of the things he said that a
country's founders who could write such
a document
and leave it to their progeny to fix
this issue of
of slavery were magnificent men
and abraham lincoln did more
for black people than any other human
being
ever in the united states ever
ever he loved this country he embraced
the constitution
he was disgusted by taney the chief
justice of the supreme court in his
ruling
uh in in the dred scott case
but he always defended the constitution
defended the founders making the point
we wouldn't even be here as a country
but for what these men did flaws and awe
and they told us
we can't fix this issue of slavery but
our children and grandchildren are going
to have to
because endowed with what
in death our rights unalienable rights
that applies to every single human
being on the face of the earth you know
when jefferson originally drafted the
declaration there were five drafts he
put a provision in there that the
british were forcing slavery on the
colony which they were
they abolished slavery but they're
extremely active in the slave trade they
were making money off it
we had borders that were very porous we
couldn't really and they kept
moving slaves selling slaves into the
united states and one of the things
that jefferson had said in there even
though he'd been a slave owner
he said this is one of the reasons and
the some of the southern states
blocked it so
you know something like that they
embraced the declaration
they knew they couldn't resolve the
slavery issue they eventually did
resolve the slavery issue like no other
country on the face of the earth no
other country had a civil war over
slavery we did
yeah and when you listen to people today
it's just that none of this ever
happened but what i was going to say is
this
about biden real fast we can come back
i'm sure
getting older so my memory pops around
you're doing just fine you're doing good
biden has always been a nasty piece of
work
when he came into the senate he cuddled
up to
james eastland and john stennis two
old southern racist segregationists
eastland was even a plantation owner
who said the most horrific things about
black people
biden called up to these guys biden
opposed
bussing a lot of people opposed bussing
including black people didn't want their
kids bust 25 miles in each direction
but biden's language was different he
used the language of the racist he
talked about
uh he didn't want his kids going into
these uh jungles and so forth he would
racial jungle that's what he said racial
jungle he would
he would say the kinds of things that
the racists would say
and then later he was tough on crime you
know he
i was the officer the crime bill used to
say of course he doesn't say it anymore
i don't have a big problem with that
crime bill by the way crime went way
down but that's a whole other story
then he shifts his position because he
sees that's not popular and now
you know he wants to be bigger than fdr
and obama and
and uh and johnson and that's all he
cares about
biden is a very dumb guy he's a he's an
egomaniac he's always wanted to be
bigger than
really his capabilities that's why he
plagiarized as a young man that's why he
stole words from robert kennedy and neil
cunning when he was running
back then we actually had standards so
that knocked him out of the running for
president yeah people don't know that he
plagiarized and that actually got him to
step down
from the democratic primary it's i think
like 88 or so
today it would be like who cares um
so he's all he's always he's always been
that way but he's always been for biden
and that's what you're seeing now biden
uh
didn't give any indication that he was
going to be like to the left of bernie
sanders
every piece of radical legislation
radical executive order radical policy
that he can put in place
he's putting in place bar none yeah bar
none i feel like we're getting hit in a
thousand directions here with this guy
right well so well that's not really
ideological it is
it is it is a personality flaw but but
do you think he's driving it at this
point that's the part that i can't
figure out it's like i don't think he
really believes in all of this stuff
you know i also think he has cognitive
problems and a whole slew of other
things
but it's like who this is what everyone
asked me the time well who's the driver
of all of this radical leftist stuff
it's obviously not 47 years in
government biden is it is it obama like
who's behind the thing
do you think at this point you know what
i think it's all that
i think he's look at his staff look at
the people throughout the government
it's like
pick the craziest bastard you possibly
can for every one of these positions
uh you want you want a guy at the
treasury overseeing
guns then pick the biggest anti-gun guy
you want somebody looking at civil
rights we'll pick a woman who hates
white people and goes on and on about
white people and so forth mark we got a
gay guy doing transportation come on
that's qualification enough isn't it
come on look there's two departments
they always give the
guys they don't care about
transportation and hud so i wouldn't
but here's the thing
i think he's told them who he wants to
be and what he wants to do
i don't think he's there working in the
weeds and all this stuff i think they're
giving him this stuff and he's happy to
sign it
i think he's there over legacy he wants
to create a legacy
for himself and he'll do almost anything
to do it
and that's what he's doing and he's also
by the way we haven't touched on it
he's creating enormous dangers overseas
he's always been an incompetent when it
comes to that and other things you know
he sat on the foreign affairs committee
signed on the judiciary committee to the
important committees
and uh he's he's been so wrong so often
that i am very worried that but before
he goes we're going to be in some kind
of war
if not with china with russia i think
iran's going to have nuclear warheads
i think this world's going to be an
absolute disaster in mess
because of him and because of the people
he's appointed so this is a very serious
time
indeed it is all right let's shift i
could do i could actually just do
history even getting away from politics
i could do history with you for hours
but
let's happy to do let's shift a little
bit from some of this because i want to
talk about the the big
tech portion of all of this because
you've been very outspoken but not only
outspoken you actually
put your money where your mouth is in
that you are not on twitter anymore
you actually tweet it out i'll read it
for everybody we'll put the tweet up
on january 8th you wrote i have
suspended my own twitter account
in protest against twitter's fascism i
ask all my followers to join me
now on parlor and rumble obviously a
couple days later parlor servers were
blown up
they are now back at least on the app
store temporarily
um but you're not happy about this you
are you are wary of centralized power
whether it comes from the government or
from big tech
i left facebook and left twitter
but i spent six weeks telling everybody
on facebook and twitter
i'm leaving the end of the year here's
where you can find me
so i wasn't foolish enough to cut my
throat
and to do facebook and twitter favors
until i was ready to do what i wanted to
do
right so we have over 5 million
followers on parlor now
we're starting to build up rumble uh we
have what five
six hundred thousand over there i
believe in entrepreneurship
you i'm i thank goodness that thank god
that we have these other platforms that
are willing to compete
um i am not going to participate
in the fascism
that is being demonstrated by these
oligarchs i'm just not going to do it
they started giving me the scarlet
letter over and over and over again i go
what are you doing
well this third party well they pick the
third parties they're left-wing third
parties they're not
i said you know what i'm not gonna
participate in this you're stealing the
data
from millions of people who follow me
and i'm telling millions of people
to unfollow you now some do and some
don't
but they've come over to these other
platforms and i
feel the position i'm in i can help some
of these other platforms i'm not an
investor in any of them not that there
be anything wrong with it but i'm not
and i i tell my folks look we this is
what i'm talking about when we open the
show you got to put your money where
your mouth is we can't just talk about
these things
i'm not opposed to other people staying
on there because they need them and they
want them and they want to build up what
they everybody's
like i said everybody has their own role
my role
is as i told you earlier get the hell
out of my face
you're gonna you're gonna start giving
me a scarlet letter every time you
disagree with me
i'm done with you it's that simple if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell